little cool here in Southern California
46 downtown le right now it's warmed
into the 50s a city defined by Fame and
glamour but like any other Los Angeles
has its dark side and what lies beneath
in the City of Angels in the words of
one crime writer is as bad as there is
the police here say it's the nation's
gang capital
neighborhoods like Compton Inglewood it
was made famous by rappers made
notorious by deadly gang yeah this is it
this is our whole little square area
Manchester the century from Prairie Tula
Breda
when she passed over on the other side
of the Prairie this English family's
again the geography of Englewood is the
history of gang crime it is the world
where Carey has lived his whole life and
it's crazy because he literally had time
food you can walk across the street and
have a shootout being run back across
the street here back in your
neighborhood again he is a [ __ ] a
soldier in the vast and complex war
that's raged for decades against their
rivals the plots you wake up every day
in it you go to sleep every day in again
you know I mean you never know what
today is going to bring I guess I mean
we can take the time here as we start
going downstream so I'll just show you
from just waking up in not knowing that
today was almost gonna be the last day
of my life
breaking up not knowing that today is a
day that I wasn't going to see the
streets again for another 16 months it's
just it's crazy you never know what the
next day is going to bring but one
thing's for sure something's going to
happen in nine ten times it's not going
to be good
sit in the hospital right here of course
all our every time we've been shot and
everything off their charts that before
always end up here syn another hospital
this is it this in jail in funerals and
that story goes back decades somebody
came up with a handgun in the 90s gang
violence was an epidemic really really
like mmmm-mmm dozens of murders a month
a cycle of revenge killing but things
are changing because the gangsters
themselves are turning young people away
from violence in the neighborhood of
watts are used to fending for themselves
this car wash and barbecue raising money
for a local family to pay for a funeral
but a place most famous for its riots in
the 60s is now the focus of the war on
gangs essentially I was shot in the face
if I had to turn the wrong way this way
instead of that way and all that because
it was close range
I was shot eight with a 45 and two with
a 38 everyone has the scars the tattoos
but gang elders like Andre a [ __ ] now
teach the local youth that there is an
alternative like he was committing our
own genocide you know ghettos are
self-cleaning ovens you got to keep her
alive first you get to the point where
you keeping them alive now we can start
educating it now economics economics
play a major part but I still have to
keep you alive before I can get to the
economic part even when you tell a child
you know don't be like
do this tell them our deposit bank and
they don't realize this visual creatures
so they watch it they hear what you're
saying but they watching what you're
doing so you have to show them and you
can't get mad of it because you used to
be like that people used to try to talk
to me you say oh here Marco he was
everything negative I could say because
I wasn't ready to change I used to do it
so now that I have changing I see people
still doing what I used to do I really
can't get mad at them I'm just here for
you when you need me and when you come
around and just hope you live through it
I hope you don't get D in jail for the
rest of your life before they turn
around car every day good with you all
right man let me know alright this is
what it looks like
elder Big Mike patrolling a school in
the [ __ ] heartland of grape Street a
gang veteran with words of warnings
there just don't get caught up in that
mess they clear all the gangs and stuff
like that got me checking job Monday I
all right
okay all right
is it working well on the frontline the
LAPD says it is even if as we witnessed
on one patrol gang shootings do still
happen it's kind of an ongoing dispute
here they pull up they see somebody
hanging out they shoot at him they hit
him sometimes they miss this time they
hit him in the arm
he's lucky gang crimes like this have
halved in six years in those halls like
Compton local officials talk of a truce
between the Bloods and the Crips the
police are skeptical of that if it is a
war on gang Sweeny can never be one no
in my opinion it can't be one we don't
you don't have the manpower as far as
officers you just got it contain a
signal there's too many gang members
it's a way of life just lose that that
fight am 1460 katie ym Inglewood
California it's a measure of how gangs
are part of the fabric here that there's
a show called gang talk on the radio
we're infecting these kids absolutely
but with a peace accord to stabilise
their circumstances to give them a
chance to live really that's really what
we're trying to do and saharan had
nothing to do with gangs until her home
was caught in the crossfire after a
while there wasn't any place in the
house where I could hide any further and
when that bullet came through the window
and hit the top of the floor wow that's
when I got enraged and I think in raised
is a fair word because I took my fear
and turned it into activism this show is
now part of those attempts to break the
cycle of violence you can't kill it you
can't squash it and you're not going to
arrest your way out of this what we were
trying to do was stop up stop stacking
up the pile of dead bodies
please didn't care about that head count
we did we did so we have to push them
and force them to allow us to have a
chance to do this and what we discovered
we have the right answer we some of them
don't even know
they don't know their case so that
involves what she calls the ex
participants men like skip Townsend a
man who paints a vivid picture of
getting out so a lot of people thought
that I was homicidal I thought that I
was some crazy guy actually I was
suicidal just imagine me dressing up
each and every day to go and be killed
to go out there not knowing that today
is my last day so there was a guy who
asked me do I love my family my
daughters and I said yes he said would
you die for him and I poked my chest
ounce an hour died for him he said are
you willing to live for him so I hadn't
understood that at that time and so for
everyone who goes out there and says I
don't care I don't care and they're out
in the streets creating some sort of
havoc it's because they gave up on
themselves and they gave up on life
turning point for me in 1998 I'm in LA
County jail facing two life sentences
followed by six years my father dies I'm
looking for someone to talk to and I
could not have an intelligent
conversation in that environment I knew
then that I already had stopped me in
violent but I knew then I had to stop
hanging around the same people I had to
change the players on the playground or
change my playground altogether it's an
automatic it's a nine-millimeter
semi-automatic there are plenty still
out there weeks after a gang shooting we
were with police when they arrested the
alleged gunman and found the weapon in
his sister's home he's a known gang
member of this area
I guess we surprised him he opened the
front door he shut it locked it went
through the bag we got him in the back
she told us what he slept we went there
people will tell you here that getting
arrested often makes you one of the
lucky ones
it was great-great-great-great boys in
the space of 52 days Cathy wouldn't lost
two sons to gang shootings that drives
her own personal war on gangs which he
says can be won no I can say the world
and I know I can't be a voice everywhere
but I know I can't be avoided I am a
voice in this community and so the
different areas that don't get along my
goal is that we start at least getting
along to the point to where we don't
shoot each other on sight but everybody
was just in disbelief there Brendan had
gotten killed in you know losing to two
kid that such a short time was so
devastating do you think they'll ever be
a day we're not yes we they were not
volumes of gold yes I'm confident of
that what do you say because there's too
many people on board it's too many
people on board with this and for those
who's not on board with it they'll be
pushed aside accounting Englewood carry
the [ __ ] has a very different opinion
it's never going to stop
this is like the same
besides commit genocide on the gang
there's no way to stop it with just to
kill them all drop a nuke and wait for
the land to clear and start over
it's the only way what happened it's
like this same if you have a roach
infested apartment you burn the building
down if you want to get rid of them all
but here's why there's some hope on the
same day we met Carrie on the building
site in Hollywood where he's just
started work a lifelong [ __ ] working
alongside Terry a blood
two men given the chance of building a
new life outside of gang crime even
though we're out of it is never over
people still know your face and you
still known out there in the streets so
this day by day just taking do what you
can to do right go on with your life
it's kind of good he's good you guys
know it's burning I ain't going to jail
I had a worry about the police
like I helicopter I finally feel like
this I got a little much more I still
got a watch over my shoulder so you see
it still know my face I got tattoos and
stuff they reflect on a war that's taken
as many as 15,000 lives and how there is
a way out for those who want to take it
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles